hello everyone and welcome back to the
penultimate round of this year's
scene-filled cup after the game uh
alireza versus wesley so we are going to
live on arunan versus yanipaneshi as
this is also uh well uh a bloodbath in
bloodbath in its own right uh but before
we check out the game uh here uh the
grand chester official account published
that um uh well that uh strange women
started gathering in front of the sinful
cup to show their support uh for hans
niemann
with uh with all sorts of signs like
hans has cool hair we love hans gen z's
love hans checkmate magnus and they even
decorated the signs with the little uh
little chess pieces so i thought you
guys
would be uh interested to notice uh now
let's check out the game uh so levon has
the white pieces and he opens with e4 we
have e5 knight to f3 and here uh knight
to f6 level uh uh nepo goes for the
petrov defense uh and uh levon goes for
the main line knight captures on e5 we
have d6 knight to f3 and
knight captures on e4 d4 d5 and now
bishop to d3 uh the classical attack
against the petrov bishop to d6 and both
players castle so castles castles and
now pawn to c4 so playing very very
seriously uh c6 rook to e1 and now
bishop to f5 so again all been played
before we have queen to c2 putting more
pressure on that e4 square and now the
should be back to g6 and now uh pawn to
c5 by island and it's a very very
interesting position looks like a very
anti-positional move since you no longer
fight for for the center but it has been
played before by some very very strong
attacking players like alexei shirov uh
vishwanathan anand played it um uh they
both win
one very nice games uh and bishop back
to c7 so here we have knight back knight
b to d2 and it is now as of move uh 11
that we have a completely new game
knight the c3 is a known move but here
levon plays knight to d2 and now
completely new territory uh and now pawn
to f5 and it's a very interesting that
knight to c3 is the engine stop
recommendation knight uh knight um beta
d2 is the engine's second recommendation
however it's saying that black will be
somewhat better
if uh you know uh uh you can play of
course you're not gonna lose the game
because of that move but uh uh it's very
interesting that the move levon chose is
uh well uh he deviates with uh with sort
of not an improvement but with uh with a
lesser move but uh you know
who who knows what um uh what lebron uh
prepared so let's see how it goes we
have queen to b3 puts pressure on the b7
pawn and now rook to f7 now of course
the pawn is defended indirectly if you
capture then just bishop captures with
check and off goes the queen so you
can't play that so after queen to b3 and
rook f7 just bishop back to c2
we have h6 by nipple and now knight to
f1 we have pawn to a5 preparing a4 so
pawn to a4 and now knight to a6
now we have bishop to d2 developing
while also stopping the
knight from coming to b4 and you really
don't care if uh if black trades if
black trades you will be very very happy
as the knight here on e4 is basically
untouchable now you're just gonna
capture and you will enjoy this position
so here bishop the h5 putting pressure
on the knight on f3 and uh well
uh it's it's not all that clear how
levon should continue this he plays rook
eight to d1 and now queen to f6 uh he
continues nipple continues to put
pressure on this d4 pawn for the moment
the knight defends it but the knight can
easily be captured and now it's not all
that clear how to continue this if you
try something like bishop to c1 yes you
add another defender to the pawn but
then you allow the knights to jump to b4
and it seems like uh for you know for
the price of that one pawn you are just
allowing nipple to activate his pieces a
bit too much so levon decides to give it
up he plays knight to g3 attacks the
bishop and basically forces the trade on
f3 so bishop captures an f3 queen
captures an f3 bishop captures and g3 we
have h captures queen captures on d4 now
grabbing that pawn
and bishop captures on a5 now if you're
wondering why not bishop captures on h6
and i know some of you were wondering
that because of queen to c4
or rather even better queen captures
than c5 now the bishop is hanging and
also this bishop is hanging so you would
just blunder the game completely so
bishop captures on a5 opens up a
discovery now comes queen captures on b2
grabbing a pawn rook to e2 defending the
bishop and now knight a captures on c5
and this is the position that uh
levon probably saw when he decided to
play this move but the problem is he's
down two pawns and how do you how do you
play this if you if you go for some like
bishop captures uh on e5 of course now
you are threatening to pick up the black
queen just uh d captures an e4 now the
white queen is hanging as well and this
is just uh completely lost uh your
bishop here is still hanging so you have
to deal with that bishop back to d2
knight captures on a4 attacks the rook
uh and really no no good move inside
captures captures and you are down uh
down three pawns so of course completely
winning for nipple so after this knight
eight captures on c5 we have bishop back
to e1
and now queen back to f6 not allowing
any nasty discoveries with the bishop we
have pawn to a5 and now rook to d8 and
now we have bishop back to b1 so nepo is
definitely better here it's only a
matter of how he will convert to this so
here he goes rook after d7 doubles up on
the d file uh planning to move the
knight then you start advancing the
pawns we have queen to a3 uh putting
pressure on this knight and also uh
perhaps having some ideas of advancing
the pawn at some point so here pawn to
d4 and bishop to be for now threatening
to win the knight here so knights the a6
and now bishop back to e1 we have pawn
to c5 as planned uh and now uh
uh
it seems that c5 although it's a move
you really wanted to play now was not
the time to play it instead of c5 you
should uh continue uh
with some other plan like knight to c7
and then and then uh
you bring the knight for example to d5
then to c3 and so on uh the problem is
with the immediate c5 is that levon has
this beautiful g4
and now of course you cannot capture as
uh you you just blundered the knight so
here pawn to g6 by nipple and now comes
queen to c1 it's very interesting that
uh
levon does not wanna uh
play something like captures captures
and bishop captures he just wins upon
back and after captures and captures he
has uh uh two rooks a queen uh a bishop
the the nephew's king is wide open so he
would have great great chances to to
play this even though nipple does have
two connected past pawns uh the wide
open black king would be very very hard
to defend so okay queen to c1 going
after the h6 pawn but now just king to
g7 we have g captures on f5 g captures
and again not going for bishop captures
for some reason uh levon plays rook to
d3 but levan always plays the most
interesting chess so who are we to
question his uh
you know
sort of reluctancy
towards pawn grabbing so here rook to e7
and now rook to f3 you have to be
careful it's good that the rook is here
because uh otherwise you just start
capturing here and the queen hangs so
rook d the e8 and now we do have rook
captures on e4 we have rook captures on
e4 bishop captures rook captures and now
bishop to d2
so what do you play here uh queen to e6
activating the queen gaining control
over the e file and queen to b1 now
putting pressure on the b7 pawn so queen
d5 defending the b7 pawn and now rook to
h3 putting pressure on the h6 pawn rook
to e6 defending and now queen to c1
putting even more pressure on this pawn
but it's not not going to be pleasant
here we have rook to g6
now you have a possibility of capturing
an h6 but checkmate is being threatened
on g2 so you have to really uh
watch your steps here but of course you
will grab the pawn as it comes with
checks so bishop captures an h6 king to
f6 and now pawn to f3
uh it's uh it's a good uh question do
you defend checkmate with g3 or with f3
uh here uh levon played pawn to f3 g3
would have been a bit more
uh sturdy but what are you gonna do uh
knights to c7 we have queen to f4 now
and uh okay the knight is hanging how do
you play this knight to e6 attacks the
queen and now queen all the way to b8 so
it seems that levon has a very very nice
attack here the king is on f6 there's a
rook of bishop and the queen ready to go
after the king
but nipple finds the
cleanest way to push for the win and
that is queen a2 again checkmate is
being threatened so how do you play uh
g4
this is one one possibility but it's
also uh the one that loses the game on
the spot but it's not uh
uh it's not easy to not to find the move
whatever you play for example you play
g3 then queen captures on a5 and now
without the a pawn your position is just
much much worse there is no
mating attack or anything here for lavon
even though the king is on f6 but the
knight is a surprisingly uh spectacular
defender here against all in every
checks so here after queen a2 we have g4
uh he he tries an idea but it doesn't
work f captures on g4 queen to h8 with
check king to f7 and now rook to g3
this is what uh he comes up with but now
there's queen to b1 with check king to
h2 queen to c2 with check king to h1
queen to d1 with czech king to h2 queen
to e2 would check rook the g2 and now
the spectacular pawn to g3 of course the
rook cannot capture the rook is pinned
the king cannot capture as the rook is
here king h3 with queen to f1 and he was
in this position on mu52 that levon
arunian resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so whatever you play rook the a queen
to h1 is coming of course you will have
to block and then this checkmate there's
uh
nothing you can do if you play something
like queen h7 uh you can just block
knights the knight to g7 you don't have
to you know
try and escape with the king there's
just no move you can play once you once
you capture of course you're just
getting checkmated queen each one check
only move and now queen captures and h2
will be checkmate
so uh very very nicely done levon played
very uh
very creatively as he usually does he
deviated with from the standard knight
c3 with knight beat to d2 lavon uh uh
nipple obviously knew how to refute the
idea as he of course uh
well knows
a lot about chess theory uh and he did
get a get a get a you know a good game
at some point the one was even better
but uh you know that's just uh in the
end uh
you know the uh as they say the player
who makes the last the
uh the last mistake uh will uh lose the
game
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh let's not forget about the
standings these are the standings after
the penultimate round uh it's a tie at
the top uh
between fabiano corona alireza and
yanipongashi who all three of them have
four and a half points however fabi was
supposed to play magnus in the final
round uh so he will remain on four and a
half points as you can see he is four
and a half out of eight and everyone
else will get a chance to
uh to improve uh i i believe
yanipongoshi is facing uh hans niemann
in the final round and alireza who is
alireza playing i will just check really
quickly already is playing mvl so uh the
big french clash in the final round uh
will uh those two
those two matches will be uh probably
what decides the uh the the fate of the
scene field cup uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it very very
nicely done by uh by nepo but also uh
you know nicely done by fabi by uh he
did have a shaky start to the tournament
but now he he uh
well uh at least he's sharing first
place uh be before the final round even
though he will not be playing in it
uh so yeah i would like to thank paul
certano which uh csf5 revision reptiles
youtube another casual coder and the
david kimura for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the final
round of the sing thingfield cup until
it finishes
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day